>> Tucker: IN 2001 LARRY
SINGER COFOUNDED WIKIPEDIA.
HE LEFT THE COMPANY SOME YEARS
AGO BUT IN THE YEARS SINCE
WIKIPEDIA HAS GONE ON TO BECOME
THE WORLD'S SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF HISTORY, OF
INFORMATION AROUND THE WORLD.
AND SO IT'S A PROBLEM, WE'VE GOT
TO PAY ATTENTION TO AND HE SAID
HIMSELF THAT WIKIPEDIA IS NO
LONGER A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
HONEST INFORMATION.
HE SAYS THE EDITORS OF WIKIPEDIA
USE HIGHLY POLITICIZED SOURCES
AND BLOCK DISSENTING NEWS
OUTLETS FROM CONTRIBUTING AT
ONCE AGAIN, THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR
ALL OF US.
LARRY SINGER JOINS US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF US WHO
USE WIKIPEDIA HAVE NOTICED.
WAIT A MINUTE, I KNOW SOME FACTS
THAT ARE SOMEHOW NOT IN THIS
ENTRY OR THEY ARE PLAYING UP
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE TRUE OR THIS IS HIGHLY
POLITICIZED.
YOU SEE THE BIGGER PICTURE HERE,
WHAT YOU THINK IS GOING ON?
>> IT'S COMPLICATED.
FOR ONE THING, WIKIPEDIA ALLOWS
ANONYMOUS CONTRIBUTION.
AND THAT MEANS THAT BECAUSE IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR SOURCES
OF INFORMATION ONLINE, THERE IS
A NATURAL INCENTIVE FOR
GOVERNMENTS AND CORPORATIONS,
CRIMINAL OPERATIONS TO BASICALLY
LEARN HOW TO PLAY THE WIKIPEDIA
GAME.
SO IT'S OPAQUE TO ME HOW IT
REALLY WORKS.
AND WHAT RESULTS IS BASICALLY
ESTABLISHMENT VIEWS ARE THE ONES
THAT YOU FIND PUSHED, AND THEY
HAVE COMPLETELY ABANDONED THE
NEUTRAL POINT OF VIEW.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE IN MY VIEW, WIKIPEDIA
SHAPED THIS COUNTRY'S
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORLD.
IT IS THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
INFORMATION FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
MOST PEOPLE ACTUALLY, ABOUT
HISTORY.
SO WE NEED TO FIX THIS.
HOW DO YOU THINK WE WOULD DO
THAT?
>> WELL, THANKS FOR ASKING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE IS A WAY
TO FIX WIKIPEDIA WITHIN
WIKIPEDIA.
IT'S AN INSTITUTIONALLY
CONSERVATIVE PLACE.
WHAT I WANT TO SEE, ACTUALLY, IS
A NEW, BASICALLY KNOWLEDGE
COMMENTS, A NETWORK OF ALL THE
WIKIPEDIA ARTICLES IN THE WORLD
COLLECTED TOGETHER AND MADE IT
EASILY SEARCHABLE.
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW THE
BLOGOSPHERE WORKS?
THERE IS A STANDARD TO COLLECT
BLOGS AND BLOG ARTICLES FROM ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
I WANT THE SAME THING TO HAPPEN
BUT WITH ENCYCLOPEDIA ARTICLES
AND IF WE DID THAT THEN WE WOULD
NO LONGER HAVE TO DEPEND ON
WIKIPEDIA AND WE WOULD HAVE,
ESPECIALLY IF WE COUPLED THAT
WITH A RATING SYSTEM, THEN WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO -- MULTIPLE
RATING SYSTEMS, ACTUALLY, THAT
WOULD ENABLE US TO FIND THE BEST
ARTICLES FROM OUR OWN POINT OF
VIEW ON EVERY SUBJECT.
AND AGAIN, WE WOULD THEN BE FREE
OF WIKIPEDIA.
>> Tucker: IT MUST KILL YOU AS
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE FOUND
IT WIKIPEDIA WHICH IS BECOME THE
CENTRAL PART OF OUR CULTURE AND
INTELLECTUAL LIFE, WEIRD AS IT
IS TO SAY, TO --
>> I'M SORRY, HOW DO I FEEL
ABOUT WHAT?
>> Tucker: YOUR ROLE IN
CREATING THIS THING THAT NOW
LEADS THE COUNTRY.
>> [LAUGHS]
I'M EMBARRASSED, TO BE QUITE
HONEST AND I'VE SAID SO FOR A
LONG TIME.
I'VE BEEN A LEADING CRITIC OF
WIKIPEDIA FOR OVER A DECADE NOW,
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING VARIOUS
THINGS TO TRY TO IMPROVE ON IT
AND I'M SORRY TO ALL THE PEOPLE
WHOSE REPUTATIONS HAVE BEEN
SULLIED BY WHAT I GOT STARTED 20
YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: GOOGLE HAS HELPED A
LOT BY PROMOTING WIKIPEDIA,
WHICH IT DOES.